Now that you have a sense of what a merging strategy could look like for
a simple file, let's take a look at how Git could use this type of
strategy to allow you to merge two branches together.
Right now, I want to create a combined version of my coins branch and
the master branch.
If all Git had was these two commits, it wouldn't be able to tell how to merge
them together, just like you couldn't tell earlier whether Jake added a line or
whether Rachel deleted it.
Luckily, Git also has a record of what the code looked like before the two
branches diverged.
This is analogous to the file that Rachel and
Jake had at the beginning of the day.
Using these three commits, Git can create a combined version of
the two branches using a similar strategy to the one you used earlier.
Commits are the basic building block of Git, so it probably isn't that
surprising to you that this combined version will also be a commit.
But what will be the parent of this new commit?
As it turns out, when you use Git to create a merge commit, that commit
stores information about both of its parents, so I'll add arrows to both.
Since the goal of this merge is to get the content from the coins branch
into the master branch, I'm going to want this new commit to be the new
tip of the master branch since the master branch is the one getting updated.
Git practitioners will often refer to this process as merging the coin
branch into the master branch.
After the merge, the master branch will include all the changes that had
before plus the changes from the coins branch.
It's sort of like creating a new commit with all the changes from the coin
branch, except that I still have access to each of these old commits.
Note that this is very different from what we would see if we took the state of
the files at this point, at the end of the coin branch, and
made a commit with that on top of master.
All that would do is basically set master to be the same state as coins, but
that's not what we want to do.
We want to have all of these changes merged in as well.
Once we've successfully merged the two branches,
we won't need an easy reference to this commit anymore.
We'll be able to reach it through the master.
So once we're done with the merge, we can delete the coin branch.
Note that when we talk about deleting branches, we mean deleting the label.
The commits will still be there in the history.
However, if no branches can reach the commit,
deleting a branch does effectively discard its commits.
So if you deleted the coins branch without merging it in first, you would
essentially be abandoning these commits since they would all become unreachable.
After you create the merge commit, which commits do you think would be included
if we ran git log on the master branch?
For each of the commits with the checkbox next to it, check whether or
not you think it would be included.